stuffed meats are perfect for special
occasions they look impressive
taste amazing but more importantly they
are so simple to do
pan on for the stuffing it's a saddle of
lamb
basically a sort of rolls-royce cut
perfectly shaped
and it suits stuffing to an absolute tea
for the stuffing finely chop an onion
garlic nice thin slices
oil in onions and garlic
in salt
and pepper make sure the stuffing is
beautifully seasoned so it helps to
season the inside
of the lamb now we've got the color on
those onions
we're gonna throw in some pine nuts and
that helps to
give a bit of a texture
here's where it starts getting really
exciting
spinach in and just lay the spinach over
the pineapples
it looks like a lot of spinach that's
going to condense and disappear
almost instantly
there's so much more flavor in spinach
when you saute it as opposed to
steaming it or boiling it gas off look
at that
now to bring that together no eggs no
breadcrumbs
crumpled feta over the spinach feta
cheese
adds a beautifully salty sharp and
creamy flavor
what this does it brings our stuffing
together
now open up the lamb
keep those little fillets to the side
that's the channel
that we want to stuff so i want to just
open that up a little bit there
salt and pepper lightly
and before we put our stuffing in we're
going to season it with
suman sumac is a wonderful lemony spice
that goes brilliantly with lamb and you
can get it in most big supermarkets
and it sort of cuts through that thick
rich sweetness of the lamb
open up that lamb there
take a spoon if you're preparing this
for the day
ahead then let the stuffing cool down
it's inevitable when you start rolling
it and tying it
something's gonna squeeze out so load up
the ends
take these beauties these little fillets
and just support
that stuffing and sort of increase
that beautiful tunnel and then from
there
over there and bring that
towards you and then roll like i said
some of the stuff is going to come out
now to tie it
first off around the side and don't
worry about some flash
butcher's knot just tie it
one in the middle you can get butcher
string from your local butcher
or at cookware shops i got two ties
go too tight it just forces all that
stuffing
out of the lamb when it's in the oven
nice
now we just season the top of it
roll the joint to make sure all the skin
gets seasoned
now you think normally that just goes in
the oven like that that's how my mum
would do it but
get your tray onto the gas oil in
get it really nicely colored none of
your stuffing is coming out the sides
really important look at that color
beautiful
does kickstart the roasting process
gas off into the oven
cook for 45 to 55 minutes depending on
how pink you want your lamb
lift the lamb out of the fat to rest
resting it raised up in the tin will
stop it cooking
but not cool it down too quickly and
means you won't lose any of those lovely
juices
next i'm making a simple but
sophisticated accompaniment
for the lamb top and tail the cucumber
peel it cut the cucumber
into three and just core
taking out all that it's just sort of
watery seedy and it spoils the flavor
slice the cucumber
cucumber in really nice way of making a
cheap and cheerful cucumber look
glamorous we're gonna dress that
cucumber
with a nice fresh yogurt couple of
tablespoons
next some fresh mint dressing a touch of
salt
a touch of pepper and then pomegranate
molasses
that just sweetens it up finish that
with lemon
mix that up
lamb it's rested carefully take off the
string
and then just gently pull them back
straight edge knife is going to cut
through that
crispy fat on the outside instantly i
tied it purposely so i can get
my portion control from the lines hold
it
nice and firmly look at your line where
the string was
and look this one is going to be amazing
lay and down just in those two slices
there
it proves that stuffing meat is for
special occasions because that is a
saddle of lamb
at its absolute best
stuffing meat and fish not only makes
them look fantastic it also gives them
an extra added flavor dimension too
once you've mastered the technique
you'll be able to turn out dishes that
will guarantee
you'll have an unforgettable feast
cooking's all about being bold and
adventurous
and this dish is exciting because it's
slowly cooked and the longer it cooks
the more flavoursome it becomes
marinating the lamb first chilis we're
going to use a mixture of red
and green take off the tops and just
slice
in garlic
crushed don't worry about chopping these
ultra fine just
get it in there cooking for up to three
hours
everything sort of blends and almost
sort of purees itself together
smoked paprika goes brilliantly well
with the chilis
two teaspoons in a touch of dried
oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance
that they give out is extraordinary they
release a little oil as well
and helps to tenderize the lamb a touch
of salt
pepper cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb
olive oil just a tablespoon
and the olive oil helps to sort of stick
all those wonderful spices
to the lamb jump in just start
really rubbing at this stage you can
leave the lamb to marinade for anything
from half an hour
to overnight allowing the spices to
really penetrate the meat
giving amazing results when you tuck in
delicious
vegetables carrots and onions and that's
it
sliced
secret slicing vegetables for brazing is
not getting too thin
you slice the onions too thin they burn
you've got that horrible char taste on
that slow braised
grazing it's just a chef's term that
means cooking in liquid on a low heat
making the meat incredibly moist and
beautifully tender
so the secret of braising is having a
really nice thick
durable pan get that nice and hot
just a touch of olive oil lamb in
hold the bone because you're in control
then into the pan
i want that white fat to start rendering
so it'll add more fat therefore making
it
a lot more flavoursome as it braises
chilies cinnamon
in mix that up and don't be scared
you're not burning this you're sort of
searing the lamb shanks and this is the
important part right at the very
beginning
we're getting the color on the lamb
which washes off as it braises in the
oven so
be generous with that color vegetables
in
wow and then a couple of baileys
so now you lift the lamb up and get the
lamb
sat on top of the vegetables now just
glaze the pan with red wine
the glazing means that you're you're
cleaning the bottom of the pan and
you're getting that amazing flavor
washed off and lifted up into that sauce
can really transform that dish
always delays then bring to the boil and
cook for about 10 minutes to reduce
the wines reduce down by half now with
the stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now don't cover it
when you cover it all the condensation
comes off the lid
your lamb becomes gray all this effort
and that exciting spice
gets washed away no lid and into the
oven
for three hours a slow cook on a low
heat of 160 degrees
gives the spices time to work and
transform the meat so it's
mouthwateringly tender
now look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat
sliding down juicy and crazy tender
grab it by the the shank roll around
that
rich delicious sauce
look at that and get your sauce
nice beautiful just get some mint
don't chop it just pick that fresh mint
and let it
snow and there you go a very spicy
delicious melting in the mouth lamb
shank
amazing
one of the secrets to slow cooking is to
be robust
and really get stuck in big bold flavors
work really well so don't be precious
this is
gutsy cooking at its absolute best
these are lamb breasts a beautiful cheap
cut and it's sort of tucked
alongside the rib they've been boned out
the skin has been taken off we're going
to roll them
stuff them and braise them braising
simply means
cooking in liquid on a low heat making
the meat divinely tender
now open them up and give them a really
good season
season them both sides inside and out
really important
it doesn't look like a real weighty
dense
cut of meat but once it's beautifully
slow braised
it's just like melting lamb it's
incredible i'm going to season the
breasts with some dried
oregano put a heat in there
some chili flakes
[Music]
lemon zest
put some amazing salted anchovies in
there now
they almost melt inside the lamb
so the balance of flavours work
beautifully
now pull it down towards you and
roll that nice and tightly
that's what i'm looking for
string i just need to tie them three
times
one at each end and one in the middle i
fell in love with this dish
years ago when i first started working
in paris
because we had all the lamin from the
pyrenees the nice thing is
they can be done the day before pan on
olive oil in
get their oil nice and hot lamin
really important to get some nice color
on there
whilst they're browning slice the onion
the lamb's gonna be cooking for two and
a half hours so don't slice the onions
too thinly otherwise they'll burn
garlic and leave whole got a color on
them
look at that beautiful take them out
onions in and garlic straight in lovely
that's the secret about slow braising
you never change
pans why all the goodness
is in that one pan a few chili seeds
in there oregano nice pinch
a little bit of lemon in there i'm gonna
do the onions what i did to the lamb
[Music]
next my capers
fry them off get them exploding at the
bottom of the pan they get nice and
crispy
next my black olives now
white wine
mmm bring that up to the boil
deglazing the pan as well i rinse in the
bottom of that pan
and now the flavour in there is just
extraordinary
now where that tomatoes
[Music]
puncture those plum tomatoes
[Music]
then simply place the lamb breast back
in the pot and remember to taste
[Music]
that's nice lid on
into the oven 170 two
two and a half hours and forget about it
[Music]
wow beautiful
all that has reduced down to this
amazing nice
tomato sauce and the lamb has kept its
color
look at that it's braised beautifully
very carefully get your little bits
there
slice off pull off the little bits of
string
this is why i get really excited the
secret is not to slice it
too thinly look at that
i can smell the lemon
it's hard to believe when you slice
through the center there that that is a
very cheap
cut of meat i'm salivating
i love this i mean it's just incredible
pick up the tomatoes and the olives and
the onions
an amazing rich sauce
take your lamb sort of just
sit it on it looks incredible
and that for me is why chefs get so
excited with
cheap cuts because the end results are
incredible
breast of lamb with lemon anchovies
chili
and oregano
you